Okay, so here's I believe the start of it. Okay, I'm pretty sure
I'm pretty sure this is the start is yesterday
>> we have we have this kickoff. Okay, >> we have
this. >> Okay, so what is S saying here?
Uh I don't know why NYSE is talking about me behind a block.
Not only did you accept real toxic, I am concerned about you.
Last time I talked to you, it felt like you were a decently happy
person at times. These days, all I see you doing on Twitter is
being very unhappy. If you were, it might be different, but it
seems like you're very seriously something. And Arerodite comes
along and says, "Why does Jtock follow Star, but not sick?" Um,
I don't know.
I follow Stardust cuz I have followed Stardust for a long time.
She was really uh she tried to help me when my YouTube channel
got banned, unlike some other people. I still >> That was
nice of her. >> Doesn't really make up for all of the rest
of everything, but you know, it was a thing. He's angry at me
because he apologized to me for being so deranged about me and
I didn't really have interest in accepting his apology.
Dardis responds, "I was wondering why he was hijacking a tweet
where I'm to rage about out about to rage out about you. Killed
the fun vibes instantly. Just made it pathetic. Honestly,
okay." And uh sorry, sick responds, "I don't know why NYSE is
talking about me behind a block. Not only did you accept my apology,
but you immediately went into talking about musician YouTubers
you hung out with cuz clout is more important to you than any
political mission that might affect real Americans.
Damn. >> Just so you know. So this is I think what started
their feud, right? >> Sick. Going after not. So now like
Stardust is just extra upset. You're hijacking my tweet to go
after her.
Stop being a weirdo. And then she just starts defending.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Uh but Sik Sik doesn't like that.
Okay. Sick doesn't like that she did that cuz he apparently immediately
goes and leaks their DMs.
>> Which is kind of funny. I didn't really have an interest
in accepting his apology. Right. You just accepted my apology
multiple times in our convo. Gave information about the transfer
of bridges. Spouted apology towards Destiny. Shamed Aaron for
violating Pixie despite Destiny doing 10 times worse. And talked
about how talked about you hanging out with musicians. Damn.
at Nazarite really showed me in those DMs. Okay, so this is him
quote tweeting himself. And do we get a Oh, there's Cherry. Do
we get a Stardust response to this? I wonder. Let's read these
DMs.
>> Oh, reading a DM again, just like old >> Oh, sure.
Are you going to be sick or
>> Uh, I'm going to be Arudite, obviously. >> Okay.
I'm >> like her biggest fan. >> All right. Not that
my word means, but I want to apologize for going so hard on you
and X. While I definitely disagree with some of your actions,
I've actively stopped roping you into the drama [__]
because I can see you care. No offense, but given the multi-threaded
relationships going on, it looks very manipulative from the outside.
And I hope you understand that that's where that that energy
is coming from. >> I do understand. I wish people would
have asked, particularly because I keep uh taking massive hits
for trying to do what is right and have been fully focused on
that.
There's a fair bit I'm willing to cover with people privately
that I can't publicly due to some legal stuff. If the equity
transfer of bridges gets down or gets done today, I'll be freed
up a lot more to speak publicly.
>> Meaning you pulling out any stake over >> No,
he's giving it all to me. >> Oh, damn. Even with his insane
tantruming,
uh, he's seeming to now want to me over or over my last three
years. But I think with how upset he seems, I just want to manage
the legal stuff first. I think she meant to type, "He's seeming
to not want to
last years." Yeah. >> Yeah. The comments have to stop.
He's already done faux admissions left and right. Dan and you
both are very bad PR, very bad PR for yourselves and Destiny.
Dan was making a comment last night and had to stop himself from
admitting he told Pixie I wouldn't pursue legal
>> To be honest, I didn't speak to Dan at all about Pixie
and Pixie never told me he had reached out. I actually distanced
myself a lot from both. Didn't communicate at all about this.
>> That's not surprising. I'm noting his comment just to
show that people can feel the ickiness with the defensive behaviors
and held back sentiments. I told her she should pursue legal
action if she would like and I supported her in any direction
she wanted to go. Yeah, I'm really disappointed and mind like
was I just fooled initially or was he remorseful at first and
became
>> Uh I this is kind of funny that uh
>> it's just funny. It's just funny. It's
Okay. Uh for the record, I understand this. The reason that looks
so bad though is by is by you being accepted or accepting of
Pixie silence. It just plays into Destiny's hand with you being
so dependent on him financially. Or at least that is/ was the
perception. It looks like you figning consideration while letting
her play into D's hand with the least resistance possible. >> You
don't tell victims what to do with their trauma. This is traumainformed
mental health 101. When someone's consent has been ripped from
them, your role is to give them maximum choice. I agree her going
public first would have been better for me. But from her perspective,
going public was a step before killing herself.
>> when I first found out about the leaks, I was very troubled
about what to do because the mental health informed thing maligned
with the PR thing. >> Misaligned. a misaligned thing.
Wait, misaligned with the PR thing. And I decided I would do
what I would do uh if PR wasn't concerned and worry about PR
after. This was true for how I approached Steven and Pixie.
>> I won't say too much about my communications with her
cuz I'm sure you've heard stuff from her anyways, but she did
say she was concerned about people essentially treating her like
a gossup climbing the ladder. >> Very. I told her that
those people didn't matter. Anyone who sees a victim as someone
just trying to grab for more doesn't matter. Their opinion is
invalid.
Sunday forced her public. She didn't choose to go public. The
best thing he did for her was insist like a psycho that she was
an extortionist because it was so insane that she had immediate
public support.
>> What? I think she had public support because she was
violated and everyone could see that.
Yeah. I just think I think also the fact that Destiny tried to
double down on that same narrative like the same day
>> with his Reddit post or whatever probably also helped
her in terms of like that not being a thing that ever really
Well, sorry it didn't take off outside of his community where
they do believe this obviously.
>> Um actually I would say I guess that's gotten more prominence
now. People sort of believe that she's I don't know doing this
just for money. Yeah. I don't know. I mean, I guess I guess she
is in that it's a civil case, but she's been wronged in some
way. Are these new logs? These are from January 25th, 2025. Sik
leaked these because of Aerodite on Twitter, apparently. >> So,
this is like days after this. Um, >> yeah, four five days
after the leaks would have happened. Yeah, >> you missed
the one at the bottom. >> I know. Sorry. I wanted to scroll
back up. I was going to say, dude, I told her those people didn't
matter. Anyone who sees a victim is someone just trying to grab
for more doesn't matter. Their opinion is invalid.
their opinion might be invalid, but you hang out and do content
with all of these people. >> Well, I'm just I'm saying
that like it's very funny to me that the person who's most attacking
her
>> is the person that Erdite's holding the mic for and
doing management for all the events for >> and then she
went on fresh and fit and sat there with Myin as he said that
and then she's been,
you know, um >> I just I can't wait for her to explain
how that was actually because, you know, it was all for Pixie.
Actually, the reason she didn't say anything in Pixie's defense
was for Pixie. I don't know if you guys know that.
Um, let's see here.
Uh, I really hope Aaron and Pixie can make some make up someday,
but I hope you realize Aaron felt very violated in that too.
She knows she up trusting Sunday. What Sunday did was unethical
>> Uh, which was good. The day it dropped was my first
day on this road trip with some of the most famous music YouTubers
that I barely know.
I can't be made to give a about that snake to be honest. It's
insane the way she painted me despite everything I've done to
support her in the past. How she dismissed Pixie. Yeah, dismissed
Pixie is second there. It all has to do with Ardite herself.
>> And also, what did did Aaron do anything that wasn't
like supposed to be private? Did she I'm just saying that like
she she might have talked, but it wasn't like she was out publicly.
She didn't make any public statements on Ardite, >> She
didn't. So, what the [__] is this?
Uh, I don't know. And how she dismissed Pixie. I don't actually
think she dismissed Pixie. So, this is a misunderstanding of
how the logs were read. Um, just to be clear, when when I think
this is talking about when Aaron makes the comment about how,
oh, she wouldn't be really or something. That's a Aaron commenting
that if we did a wellness check, Pixie would say, "No, I was
just doing this for attention." Oh, was something about I think
Aaron says like, "Oh, Pixie would just say she was doing it for
attention or something." where she said she would just do this
for it was her talking about if there was a wellness check that's
what she would tell the ambulance people not like that that's
how she felt Pixie was acting at the time >> also can we
just be realight
what has Arodite done for Aaron I don't know what she's done
for Aaron besides make Aaron look really good and make Aaron
look like she knows what the [__] whistleblower is
and not you >> yeah sure
uh the best thing he did for was insist extortionist. Hold on.
I'm uh I think this is where we were now, right? Yeah. Yeah.
Unfortunately, he said things he did about her. Uh he said the
things he did about her because he's now
viewed so crazy in all the communities following this that he
can't grow from it like he had hoped.
Okay. It's about Sunday. I don't I'm sure Sunday might have thought
about growth with all of that. I I feel like a lot more he was
like, "Yeah, get this guy." I >> If he thought about growth,
he would have kept streaming and he didn't. He took a break.
He did take a break. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. I'm just saying. Yeah.
I feel like it was mostly uh feeling like Destiny was evil. >> In
a lot of ways. >> how do I get I can't get that to show
up on screen, so you just have to read it.
>> so Erdite says tried to figure out how to manipulate
her into doing what she wanted, what he wanted.
>> Uh I think that is into doing tried to figure out how
to manipulate into doing what she wanted. >> This is projection.
Arrodite literally in this she says that she's supporting Pixie
in whatever she wants to do. But the moment Pixie wants money,
Erdite's like, "Well, I don't I can't get involved." And she
she's pretty weasly about how she justifies backing off on that,
like it doesn't that doesn't have an effect on making Pixie maybe
feel insecure about going that path. Oh, am I no longer getting
support? That's definitely a very real criticism of Ardite that
I have never seen her grapple with is when when Pixie goes, I
want money from this. And she goes, whoa, I can't be a part of
this anymore. There's like an amount of judgment there that you
should probably be aware of if you're, you know, some kind of
like learned if you've gone and gotten an education. It's like
I feel like you should be able to see that that's happening.
>> No, but she did see cuz with Steven, she could lay out
every avenue, all of his >> Stephen, this is how you act
like a human. Okay, here are the here's the pros and cons of
being a human.
>> Very cool. Uh yeah, we will have to disagree on the
straight raid event, but that's fine. I appreciate you telling
me your perspective on her if you don't mind me asking. Is there
an unofficial private stance on Steve or are you still working
on that?
>> I do mind just because I can't really trust anyone right
now. Not going to lie, someone who feels I was somehow more awful
than Aaron, I just don't want to give a statement to. don't want
to give statements to
>> uh I think
I I would say probably I don't know that I would have had a ton
of judgment. I forget exactly where I was on this. I didn't have
a lot of judgment on Aerodite like immediately after. I think
I was pretty defensive of her. But obviously, you know, we're
now what 9 months away from from this conversation. It's like
pretty obvious who the bad person was now.
>> It's just not that hard to decide, not that hard to
figure out. >> But that's okay cuz she's calling Aaron
a communist. So, she's going to make it out on top. Hopefully,
>> that's totally fine.
Uh, that's totally fine. Also, just to be clear, you aren't giving
me a statement, but yeah, I totally get it. Just wanted to apologize
for some of my behaviors. Kept kept it more reserved after the
Tom video cuz I wanted to talk to you first before I decide how
I feel or sorry, how to feel. But yeah.
>> Yeah. But I also didn't expect multiple friends to go
on a tear about me without even asking for my side. Aaron, Becket,
etc. I appreciate the apology. I do.
>> I think Aaron had the same mindset a lot of people do
or did. You did you did do a whole hourong talking about how
you're basically married to the Bridges business venture for
this foreseeable future and that was after the leaks.
>> It is just tough because it's a little hollow compared
to the amount of insane like
any even neutral read into the situation. people who I thought
knew me better uh than that gave me. Like one, it was filmed
hours after the claim of the non-consent.
Two,
it was not an hour video of being married to Bridges. Unless
you just rewrite the entire combo and are aiming to be bad faith
towards me, to be >> Hold on. Is this talking about the
Turkey Tom interview? >> Yes. Yes. So, she recorded the
Turkey Tom thing before the stuff about me came out, but Turkey
Tom brought it up. >> Yeah. Before she knew Yeah. >> before
she knew all the details. Um, guess they probably did it like
an hour or something after.
>> Uh,
Right.
>> I They did it They did it somewhere in the middle. They
did it like the next day or something. I don't know. >> Maybe.
But, bro, this [__] love calling people bad faith.
>> She do.
You do. She >> know. If you heard it that way, I guess
you could be bad faith. If you don't know what I'm talking about,
I'm referring to the video you g of giving your experience trying
to be inside the country legally. Oh no, it's not the turkey
interview. That was like 1.5 to two months ago, but I might be
wrong on the timeline. Hey, I got to go take care of my kiddo.
Sorry if I basically if basically married to the Bridg's business
venture sounds accusatory or implicating in any sense the value
of your in any sense the value of your character. Take care of
yourself. So he's talking about a video she did on her channel
where like after those leaks, after the November leaks, >> she
put out a video
two videos with Nick and there's like >> one of them is
really weird where they talk about who would be
>> yeah well no the termites is before then but I think
they had one where they talked about who would be loyal to
that was a weird one
they go through like a whole bunch of people like I think this
person would be loyal I think this person would be loyal this
person >> very strange stuff okay so then from there this
was how oh wait hold on I actually might need that tweet still
Give me a second. I might need that tweet because I do want to
go see if anybody quote tweets this to respond.
Stardust response or anything? >> I think Sard does >> few
quotes Stardust.
I get you have a fight with NYSE, but is really unnecessary to
hijack my tweet or sorry, is it really necessary to hijack my
tweet for your grievances? I'm literally and you're going on
and on and on and on. It's [__] rude and annoying.
I'm literally blocked by Destiny on all platforms. I even made
a graphic for Nicholas Yorio when one of the original hate streams
was put out. I feel I hate streams. Hold on. Can somebody get
this tweet to Nicholas? I believe Stardust by Nicholas's standard
is snarking on him. Stardust just said it was it was a hate stream
that he did on Destiny. Not something that he like, >> you
know, not not a totally nuanced good faith interpretation of
the all of the evidence. All right. I believe she's implying
Nicholas Dioro was going crazy,
Uh I feel I should be able to go to other topics now. Is it really
too much for me to ask you not to hijack my tweets with your
does sick respond? Have you ever apologized to this person for
falsely smearing him as a terrorist based on nothing except your
ignorance of Yemeni gun laws?
Who the [__] has access to boats and hostages?
What the [__] Oh, hi. You're muted.
>> It's dumb as hell. It's
>> Did you read any of these? Did you look at any of these?
I I I watched Aiden's stream, but I've just seen this one on
your stream. Wow. >> How did you watch Aiden's stream?
Oh, on your kick stream or something. >> Yeah. Yeah. Um
cuz I didn't want to cover this. I'm going to go find all the
tweets. It was too much effort.
>> Oh, that's how I felt. Yeah. >> She She's saying
how how does he have access to the boats? It was a tourist attraction.
They turned it into a tourist thing. You >> about the kids.
>> You know the first Yeah, about the only kid. You don't
know the first thing about this. You stupid [__]
You're [__] they're propping probably up Ethan Clyde
the whole time. >> Oh, fair enough. I thought I just thought
maybe she would actually tangibly respond to six like leaking
of the DMs and doesn't seem like she did. We got any quote tweets
here? Nope. Just a repost. >> Did you Did you see the deleted
tweet?
>> Yeah, I got I think those are archived somewhere. I
think read archive those. >> So, I I haven't pulled them
up yet cuz I was going back. Apparently, there's that there's
fight started like whatever a week ago, >> right? Four
days ago. >> Okay. This is this is before that. Okay. >> And
then this is uh this is where it goes to. This is where Aiden
started. I look I listened to him for like a few minutes just
to see if if I could get an idea of where this all started. So
I think this was it is Frogan tweets a couple days ago just got
hate crime in public but she concluded what she said or but she
concluded what she said was
the lady with the big
but she concluded what she said. I sorry the English is broken
there. Legit. I hope that you're okay if you aren't joking. very
sorry that you've gone through that unacceptable and very scary
change in the environment recently.
>> This is weird from Stardust. Just odd. >> yeah,
we where V signal hope.
>> dude.
Wasn't blocked a couple days ago and blocked now. It's hard to
find
>> Yeah, that's fair. >> It's okay. I'm fine. >> You
know, I I even Frogan doesn't deserve to be hate crime. Even
Even Froggen doesn't deserve to have hate crime done to her.
Actually, I'm going to stand on that one.
I need to tweet that. >> Stunning and brave. Yeah. Yeah.
No. Wait. Speaking of even this person doesn't deserve to be
hate crime. I'm assuming you're aware of Darius getting called
the hard R at an America event >> by uh by Destiny's new
girlfriend. Yeah. Who's there's no romantic attraction. Nothing's
happening.
>> Um I mean, we could get really skitso about it. I know.
Not even really skitso, but uh somebody in my community linked
me like some tweets, some messages showing that they were in
the same city like a couple months ago. I didn't ever run with
it cuz I was like whatever. But there seems to be like some connection
there. Any case, >> I just want to find like what is she
like your adoptive daughter? Is that what's going on? Like what
is the connection? There's nothing romantic or anything happening
here. What's happening here? >> If there's nothing romantic
or happening, isn't that worse? you're just as a random decision
deciding to bring a who yells slurs and spits on people to your
own America event. Like at least if there was some bias from
a relationship or a romantic relationship, maybe you have some
way of defending that. But I or or like at least it's emotion,
but you're just saying purely with no just logically I'm going
to bring this person. Why? I >> Does he get paid by the
person that shows up? >> Z really likes having the big
crowd. I don't know. >> I don't know.
I don't know.
I got I got nothing. >> I didn't give a [__]
about it. I still don't really give a [__] about
it, but it's just so crazy and stupid to take it to an America
event. It's just like what what are you doing? >> I don't
care about it from Destiny's
>> Hilarious from the other people. >> It's so funny
for like the counterpoints eroderites of the world. Like that's
where I find it funny, right? That they'll just keep swinging
for this guy. He'll keep doing >> his risky behavior stopped.
His risky behavior stopped. Okay, he got on
>> and he's he's not going to [__] like in
insane. Insane.
>> Like
I don't even know what to How do you describe
>> She's over 18. He said, "So long as they don't care
what you do, right? >> Why don't [__] kids?"
Got it. Got it.
>> I guess that is the that is the line. That's what the
original drama was about. Kids, right? or no it wasn't sorry
the joke is no it wasn't at all until we realized later
>> no no one [__] it just be totally clear
>> there was no successful attempt okay there were attempts
but hey there was no successful attempt at [__] the
kid okay it's it is what it is all right um sik accuses Stardust
of taking Briana Woo money to to make the video about
>> didn't you make an entire video framing her as an anti-semite
in a video commissioned by Brianna Woo now you're concerned about
her well-being. H >> for sure. >> I I actually don't
know if this is true. I know Becket talked about this [__]
but I don't know if this is true. You got any idea? >> I
don't think it's true.
>> I've never heard that. >> Uh Becket talked about
how Brianna Woo was trying to commission people to either do
research on people or to make hit pieces for her and then but
Becket never said that there was somebody where it happened like
actually quite
>> Oh, to do hit pieces. >> Yeah. So, so six saying
this. I think he's connecting dots. I don't think he knows that
this really happened.
>> Yeah, I think he's connecting dots.
>> Confusing things
candle put together. >> Yeah, Brianna Woo uh tweeted
Stardust video out and was like showing it. So, I think he's
just like
kind of firing off in the dark or getting confused or something.
>> Yeah. Well, I think I don't know if
I don't know if that was if he implied that or something. I remember
Becket talking about it to me, but I just I can't remember who
he talked about it with. I took notes on the conversation, but
I don't remember where they are.
Uh,
>> wait, what the >> I'm showing the actual start
of that >> Oh, the start of the original one. Okay, >> Yeah.
Yeah. Which is calling hijacking her tweet. back for the original
Stardust conversation. It was about Drew Pavlau and that's why
Stardust was mad. It was for Drew Pavlu tweet, right?
>> He is.
Um, but sick came in there and said, "If we're deporting fake
pathetic asses for lols, I'm on board at Nazerite. You're up."
Kind of a funny
Real talk, Sick. I'm concerned about you last time I dudes. So,
how can we get some virtue signaling uh footage of Stardust when
she deals with Ethan Klein being told, "Ethan, you're crashing
out. Ethan, you're mentally ill." >> I guarantee you I've
seen her crash the out about those comments. But when it's >> disgusting
that people pretend to care what your mental trying to get you
to stop talking on the internet. >> Uh yeah, apparently
these people will all say endlessly.
>> Yep. Yep. >> All right. And then after this, dude,
the sick had a lot of tweets here. We're getting them all. It's
the link to the
>> So after that he says >> just keeping a record.
>> So Oh, I wanted to see the rest of this. Oh, I hope
you're okay. But it seems like you're serious. You're very seriously
negative. I hope you're okay. I'm living a fulfilling life as
a single father. I am fine. This is the internet photo taken
like 5 minutes ago. Nothing to be concerned about.
Glad to hear.
Were you glad to hear though? >> Glad to hear. See, I think
when he posted this photo that lived in her head, rent free.
Maybe. And that's why she does her weird profile pick switch.
>> Maybe he I We have to figure out We have to get to the
bottom of what's going on with this profile picture. Okay. Cuz
cuz the accusation from Once we get to it, the accusation from
Sick is confusing to
>> A little confusing to me. Like what precisely the accusation
is.
Well, the accusation that Well, you know about his history, right?
>> Uh, so I know about all like a bunch of his history.
I don't know if he had nudes leaked of him. Oh, >> okay.
Okay. >> But that was like the the overall like thing I
believe that happened. We'll get to it a little bit after cuz
it doesn't happen until yesterday, the 21st, I >> Yeah.
Yeah. >> So, there's another one that comes shortly after
this. I make a joke about Oh, sorry. This is Stardust responding.
Hold on. Where do we have This is 4. So, a little bit later.
responds at 5:00 p.m. And then, wait, did something happen in
between these things? Glad to hear at 5:00 p.m. And then at 10
p.m., I make a joke about bringing someone to the US just to
deport them. Sick on chain decides to hijack my tweet for his
grievances with not so Aerodite. I poke fun. He crashes out and
dumps DMs with not soite that have nothing to do with me. The
You look deranged. Leave me alone, [__] Clown face.
You look weird as Leave me alone. Jesus Christ.
That's sick and chained. You [__] weirdo. Why are
you liking my tweets? I'm actually going to >> Wait, sick.
Totally won. What the
>> You're so weird. You like my tweets. You're so weird.
>> Wait, I didn't I've never seen this before. Oh my god,
dude. What? Okay, that I'm sorry. I wasn't sure I was, but that
100%. >> That's crazy. Maybe I just start liking Starless
tweets. That's Is that how you get her? Is this Is this new tech,
>> dude? What the out of nowhere?
Uh, does Sick respond? He doesn't respond.
Dude, that's crazy to go in like stardust mental with this with
this one simple track. >> I can't believe this is a post.
What the I also don't know what happened in between. Like at
some point
she was like, "Oh, all good." Or like, "Glad you look good now.
Oh, I bet you I bet you sick actually post the DMs after this
or something." Right. >> The the notaryite DMs. >> Yeah.
Yeah. Yeah. >> And then that's why I feel like she is upset
that
um her tweet is being used to go after Arerodite. She probably
likes Arodite or is like loyal to Arodite, which is fine, but
um it comes off not so good or it leads her to do not good things.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Here we go. Okay. So, this was all at whatever
9:00 p.m. And Stardust goes after that. know that these people
use the words fanfiction in any serious fashion. They reconstruct
reality to fit their own girl boss
Okay. Okay. All right. Finally,
I think we're ready to move on to the 21st now.
The the exchange there. Where is this one? This one. Finally,
the Frogan didn't even deserve to get war crime post. So, Sardus
response to Froggen. >> They crimed. >> War crime.
>> You're right. Stardust does deserve to be war crimes.
You're right. Thank you for correcting me. >> There's a
horrible There's a horrible misspeak on my part. >> You
just deserve Stardust. Froen that time as well, but you know,
I can get on board with that. So, >> I said I thought I
said Stardust the first time. >> No, you said Frogan. It
was about
>> Oh, I just wanted to say Sardos deserves war crimes,
but I >> We're just left and right. >> I That's immediately
where my head went. I don't think Frogan does deserve war crimes.
So unlucky. Okay. Legit. I hope you're okay. Uh, all of this
virtue signal. Didn't you make this Brianna Woo piece? That's
where we were. Brianna Woo never commissioned anything I've made.
She got the idea to look at Froggen herself after I'd already
made my videos. I can think someone is engaging in anti-semitism
and not be okay with them being hurt.
That's probably true.
Um,
I don't know why after you've done a whole bunch of hippies on
somebody, you'd go like, I hope you're okay now.
Anyway, weird. Apologies. I didn't realize framing her as an
anti-semite was your own idea. I'll be more careful next time.
Well, Froggen is an anti-semite. This is where this person comes
in. This person starts going hard in the paint. Well, Froggen
is an anti-semite. She uses Zionist because it's more ambiguous
than saying Jew. She used she used loves Sabra in her Arab to
tier list because it's a hummus from Israel and Sabra means a
born in Israel. This is the most Zog Nicholas Dioro like slob
consumer
on planet Earth right here. It's just like actual an actual NPC
with no
plug. >> Yeah, that's crazy. Oh, I don't want to go check
their profile, but I didn't want to see if anybody responded.
She's got more stuff that um people told her to say.
now is this where we do the break? I think this is where the
break happens where we need to go to the the archive
right? Oh, nope. This isn't the break yet, is it? Hold on. Would
this be it? This is the archive we've got.
Oh, yes. Oh, this is the archive we needed. Imagine making up
lies about me when I can just tell the truth about you. You insulted
your sister and you're so salty that you were held accountable
for it. >> This is h I've been like I've been kind of trying
to have a dialogue with Hutch on Twitter. >> Yeah. And
because Sik sometimes like defends, you know, how Hutch is like
kind of biased in his coverage or
>> Bias about what he's willing to talk to and what's uh
just drama slop to him. >> And somebody pointed out to
him, hey, this guy his sister and Hutch just he's like, oh wow,
this this weirdo's been in my in my replies and just blocked
sick. Like didn't look any further.
Just didn't care.
>> Yeah. Unfortunately, my first exposure to this. So,
that's it's kind of dickish. And especially when you know the
context, it's super >> Yeah, I I do know the context. And
it's like, well, any day now, Hutch, you could have a conversation
any day. You could stop looking like a idiot on the internet.
But go ahead. Keep doing you. >> Yeah. I think >> I'm
disgusted by anyone using this to get sick. Anyone that brings
us up to get a cheap sick
knew exactly what I was going to say here. >> Yeah. I couldn't
even knew exactly. How how would you even how do you even bring
yourself to do something at someone? >> The first time
I'd ever heard this is when Queen was like, "Didn't you see President
Sunday say this to Sick before?" It was really funny. And then
we I watched it and I I was like, "Oh, that was kind of funny."
And then we watch a little bit more and sick like gives the context.
I'm like, "Oh, I feel like dog for laughing now." Like that's
not like in a real sense. Okay, you can laugh at certain things
on the internet cuz you're in a goofy place. All right, but realistically,
and just in case you guys don't know where we're going, it's
in the next tweet, so we'll get there. But the context is uh
Sik was a victim of something when he was a kid. He's a CSA victim.
All right? And this is when he was younger than 10. And then
when he was 10, he reenacted that abuse on his sister. And I
think he kind of, you know, had a couple drinks one night and
talked about how this is like with his life in some ways, right?
So
it sucks. It's it's mean. It's It's really bad or whatever, but
I don't know. It It's not mean. I don't know why I said it's
mean. I Dude, I hate talking about [__] like this.
I just want to like get out of here when I immediately bring
it up, but it's it's it's something that happened to him. I'
I've I just get awkward when I talk about like CSA and stuff.
I just it like I don't know. It feels like to talk about >> I
just pretend he's Mr. Girl. >> Now you just made it funny
again. And that's on you.
>> Let's watch six Mr. Girl callins. Let's watch his advice
and confessions callins. Let's get the context here. >> I'm
good. I'm good. I'm good. Anyway, >> it's it's such a it's
it's cringe. It's cringe from people who know the whole >> Yeah.
To to just weaponize this and say, "Oh, you your sister" or something
instead of like actually saying what the rule uh saying what
the the tweets are or whatever. Um apparently Sik responds right
under this. I believe he responds right under this because we
have the
right. Yeah. Yeah. Sick responds right under it. Okay. So sick
responds to that Stardust tweet with, "I was 10 years old and
a CSA victim. In case you need to know what a 10-year-old looks
like before you decide that condemns them for life, here's one
of for you. I don't know if this is sick or sick posting a picture
of someone else." >> I think it's the AI generated thing.
>> AI generated. >> S just picked the 10-year-old
of choice. A 10-year-old of choice. He's like
>> Probably a stock photo. Hopefully. Hopefully stock photo.
Um it's not finding fault with you for being a victim. I'm finding
fault with you for being angry that you were held accountable
for victimizing someone >> which is just this is actually
so brain damaged. Well, I think probably Sik feels like here's
here's what I assume that means without knowing and then we can
go into it. I assume that means that sick feels like he was judged
by his family. And realistically, if they were if they were family
and they should love him unconditionally, especially when he's
a 10-year-old, they should be willing to understand that he probably
wasn't somebody who was like forming agency to harm someone else.
He was probably reenacting something terrible done to himself
without understanding the full consequences of it. Right. >> But
she understands that she's >> she does. And she's saying
you're mad that you were you were held accountable. And it's
like what do you mean held account? How are you holding a 10-year-old
accountable? It's a 10-year-old. What do you mean hold them accountable?
You understand like everybody has broadly decided that somebody
at that age is not really accountable for anything they do, right?
Like like they have not they can't be held accountable in a legal
sense for like almost anything they do. They are not a fully
formed adult. They don't have a fully formed like understanding
of morality and all how the world works. You can't hold them
accountable in the same way you'd hold an adult accountable.
So holding this like 30-year-old man accountable for the thing
he did when he was 10 is insane, >> you guys. She's not
brain damage. She's like playing sides. That's all this is.
>> It's Yeah, it's pretty goofy. And also, so anyway, she's
she's doing all this. It's just, you know, classic Stardust.
Oh, this was the worst. This was the absolute worst comment though.
All right, not to get away from Stardust for too long, but the
same golem appears down here, okay, and says, "So, you were the
same age as Mary Bell when she committed her first murder. You
can have bad things happen to you and still be a bad person.
You can't continuously blame what happened to you as a kid for
what you do now." >> I think you go on to be a bad person
when you don't have the adequate attention and care
um and discipline from adults to get through the trauma that
happened to you as a child. So, it's like a a valid point to
make.
>> About the the lapse in care and compassion from your
family moving forward after what happened to you. >> Yeah.
If you feel angry about that, if you feel angry that like you
feel like your family took her side or cast you out in some way
after you were a 10-year-old because this happened, I feel like
that's justified. That's totally justified. Like you you should
feel like you were betrayed.
>> Yeah.
Dude, I lose it on this Lydia Kravitz person, though. This is
crazy [__] Uh, I've never So, Sik responds to Stardust
and says, "I've never denied what happened. People know what
happened because I chose to talk about it openly on three separate
occasions. I've never been against the separation of me and my
family members during childhood." Uh, oh, me and my family members.
Sorry, this is specifically the sister, I'm assuming, during
childhood. I have never condoned my actions. I've never had animosity
towards the people who did the correct things to prevent further
behaviors. My sole grievance was people in my real life continuing
the stigma as if I was a perpetual vector for harm for a thing
I that most abused children do or grow out of. I've only ever
blocked people who choose to bring it up while conveniently sidestepping
the very real crimes grown men like Destiny have committed. Stardust,
I made one troll comment about NSE and you had a Twitter meltdown
over the course of a couple hours. I made a comment about the
video you made not commissioned by Briana uh not not commissioned
by Brianna Woo and you were weaponizing my trauma and my sister's
trauma taking uh talking about accountability as if it's ever
been relevant to my character 23 years after the fact. Sincerely,
you're a joke. The fact that you think on principle or anything
else is a W. Sorry, the fact that you think on principle or anything
else is a W is hilarious.
I don't. This is a little >> Have you seen this clip of
Hassan saying that people would be allowed dogs in the communist
utopia?
>> I have not. Uh I can guarantee you what people are liking
and memeing about this situation. And it's the same people unwilling
to hold their very dear 38-year-old revengeorn enthusiast voyer
loving streamer accountable. I won't address this situation with
you again. I hate you on principle in the same way I hate all
people who look at child victims the way you're doing it right
now. Uh, it's wrong when people leverage Destiny's child abuse.
It's wrong when they did it to Mileyopoulos. It's wrong when
they do it to me. When you do it to me, uh, and when people weaponize
my family members trauma,
>> and it's crazy because, uh, Sik has been like replying
to stuff. Um, I think this started to this this happened to him
because he was replying to Hutch and just pointing out how like,
oh, you're covering like Kaya gate. You're covering like the
shot caller more than you did the
what CS Cam allegations. And then somebody told Hutch like, "Hey,
this guy
>> sister." And then somebody was like, "Hey, does Taylor
Loren like why is Taylor Loren following a dude who raped his
sister?" They just started going to everybody who's like engaged
with him or who's replying to him or anything bringing this up
out of context and then here just decided, yeah, I don't like
that you did this to NY, so I'm going to jump on board. >> That's
even more disgusting than I >> And Hutch just listened
to the dude and blocked him. >> That's very [__]
up. Yeah,
that's >> wouldn't be the first time Hutch just listens
to a random person on the internet and decides, "Whoa, that's
a bad person." You know what good people do? They make YouTube
streams with with titles that say Hutch Defense Squad and then
Hutch goes and joins their stream and hangs out. That's what
good people do. Like an example of a good person. It's the kind
of people Hutch can hang out with. You know, >> kind of
to good people. What are you saying right now, bro? >> I'm
saying Hutch thinks are good people
>> I'm trying to I'm trying to emulate Hutch's mindset.
Okay. Yeah. Yeah.
And a lot of these same reply people on Twitter. I'm guessing
a lot of the people who
reply to sick and try to use that against him, they'll totally
go hang out with somebody who as an adult dreams about a 10-year-old.
Wow. Anyway,
I don't did I wonder if Stardust tried to say anything back.
Oh, sorry. I didn't actually read her latest tweet
>> Uh I didn't say you denied it. This is her response
to sick, but you quite literally seem very bitter that you were
held accountable for victimizing someone else.
How? Where? He literally just said he wasn't bitter at his family
for separating them. He was bitter about being treated as an
adult. Like an adult. Sorry. >> They go through the effort
of explaining themselves and you just repeat the same >> Like
I am so sick of these team sport
>> It's
she is like a golem who happened to be raised up earlier. Okay.
It's like a golem lieutenant or something.
I empathize with you. I see the pain in your eyes. I actually
I don't there's not a platform where I can operate within the
toos after reading this.
Hey. Yeah. When I when I go around and and like weaponize this
against you, I I empathize with you and I see the pain in your
eyes. >> The pain I'm recausing, >> bro. Stardust
needs to find an incredibly tall building and then do a Peter
Pan impression. I don't know. That's as close as I can get without
actually saying it. Holy [__]
This is so This is so beyond disgusting. And it's precisely it
is precisely what she freaked out about people doing to Ethan
Klein. Right. >> A joke. >> I'm just worried about
you, Ethan. I just think you're really going down a dark path,
Ethan. >> A joke. Like a going back to Canada joke.
This is worth it.
>> This is fair. >> Apparently. I don't This is like
>> Well, she's going to go on to call him a
>> It's It's actually like insane. And he he literally
>> think should be like denaturalized and deported or whatever
to to just get rid of out the US. >> Like the proteins
in her body should be denatured via like a method. >> Should
be sent to the UK. >> She should be hit with a
>> photon. Stop wait.
We should chill. >> I think she should have to live in
the UK where we put all the other people we don't want to deal
with. >> Why? That's where all of her people are. >> I
think that's where Quean is. I'm just trying to make his life.
Well, he's not one of them, but he's not an he's not an ethic
majority. Okay, Drew Pavlu tried to save him and Queen's not
even thankful for it. Okay, actually, dude, this is >> the
ghost. >> Oh, it's so I I have a hard time after this.
This is like
holy reading this statement right now after after weaponizing
against this weaponizing this against him and then repeating
the same [__] after he explained this and said hey
being separated was fine but then when I'm a 30-year-old some
of my family members still treat me like I'm going to hurt a
kid which is up because I didn't do anything that I meant to
do like I was not trying to hurt people. I was a kid I couldn't
help it right and now I'm being judged for >> Wow, you
sound bitter. >> Why do Yeah, dude.
Oh, like if you if you are a human being, if you have any amount
of like empathy or understanding in you at all,
you would go, "Oh, yeah, you were a kid. Oh, I misunderstood
the situation. You know what? I you you're upset with your family
members for being like treating you like a when you're an adult
when you obviously went through the work of trying to become
like a normal functioning human being later on." Yeah, dude.
It's crazy.
>> Wait, wait. I've got I've got a great there's a great
uh tweet for this.
Where is it? Here it is. This Alex tweet about Nick.
It's true. >> Yeah. No, we can apply this to the starter
situation. Let me finish start last post and then we'll uh we'll
get over to it. Okay. I didn't say you denied it. She's saying
to sick, but you quite literally seem very bitter that you were
that they that you were held accountable for victimizing someone
else. I empathize with you. I see the pain in your eyes, but
you act like a psycho and obsessively reply to specific women
who it's convenient for you to target to elevate your own vendettas.
You know what's what uh you know that it's in to be to me and
you thought you could get away with being a to me on multiple
occasions without me hitting back. I will not take it. It's clear
you still want some sort of justice for what you feel your sister
inflicted on you, but I am not your vector.
Dude, we need something worse than whatever the Nick thing is.
But Jesus is
>> pull the full version. But the full
I'm sending you full one. I'm sending to >> Okay. Okay.
Right here.
>> Know you've been saying we need to find a way to make
some money. >> For sure. >> I got the perfect way.
>> What's the
>> man? What the [__] we going to do with that?
Trust me.
Trust me. Come on. Come here. Take a walk with me.
>> Run that [__] dead.
>> I hope you order Dr. Peppe and they give your ass coke.
I hope you eat two Popeyes biscuits and you choke. I hope one
day you just get stranded in the jungle and get raped by a hope
you trying to rap a present and you can't find a tape. I hope
you go get new J's and they turn out to be fake. I hope you win
the trip to Africa and choke on the break. Hope you decide to
take a run and go get bit by a snake. I hope your nana cook spaghetti
and they run out of plates. I hope your boyfriend your mama and
record it. I hope your little brother found washing powder and
he snort it. I hope your motor blow out. I hope you catch a blowout.
I hope your uncle lose his w every time he go out. I hope you
break your neck. I hope you break your spinal cord. Hope your
little sister fall off a bike and break her handlebars. I hope
you cut your hand on some glass. I hope a homeless person beat
you up and spit on your ass. I hope you go enroll in college
and don't pass your lit class. I hope you fall in some gas. I
hope your kids get
beat on their ass. I hope you falling some stairs and your knee
up. I hope you get in the fight at Walmart and get beat up. I
hope YOU WIN BLOW YOUR I HOPE YOUR kids catch a heat stroke playing
on a seesaw. I hope I take you on a date and get you peed on.
I hope you die choking on the t-bone. I hope on all your wedding
pictures grandma smile without a tone. I hope you got a stalker
and your snap location be on. I hope your steering wheel lock
on the curve and hit a pole. I hope you can't get out and explode.
I hope your grandpa life insurance cancel. I hope you throw a
party. I'm a cring. You know I really hate your family
just like me without a daddy. I hope for Halloween they give
them pills that look >> I hope you crash head first into
a bus full of
catch on fire from the floor. I hope you never find out who your
baby for. And I hope you know I'm serious. I can't make this
up. I hope your brother your sister and get her pregnant. [__]
I might just post a couple pictures of you naked. [__]
I hope you wake up in your dog.
I hope your brother get his head bust online.
Hope you at your BM house and I walk out.
She lick my balls and kiss you in your mouth.
She gone. Let my dog knock off
my dog to steal them TVs out your house, [__]
>> that's pretty incredible. That's pretty good. See you,
Kio.
Dude. Okay, back to this tweet thread because I don't think we're
done yet, >> right? Oh, we're not done yet. >> There's
replies.
Oh, I don't know if you want to go over
>> No, I do want to go through.
There's this one. Oh, yeah. I was I was 10 years old when I did
a bad thing, dumbass. It didn't happen as an adult. You expressed
how bitter you are towards your sister and your family as an
adult. Your sister can't help her my her memories. Hold on. Also,
his sister is entitled to boundaries, and that bitterness reads
as a lack of remorse. Unfortunately, Small Talk doesn't believe
in boundaries. That's why her and loser box promote Diddy Saltman.
>> OH. OH, NO. WE do need these replies cuz >> something
on there. >> Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
Unfort Oh, sorry. You're defending a You lie about Stardust stealing
your name when you stole hers. Defending a what?
>> wait. That's on the
>> Is that on this thread? >> Um, yeah, I think so.
I think it's under this reply right here. If I click through
to this one. >> Um, what the would you know about boundaries
again? Oh, sorry. You're defending a you lie about Stardust stealing
your name when you stole hers. What the would you know about
Okay. Uh, again,
she was called Small Talk when I was engaging with her. If I
wanted to steal her name, why would I call myself Stardust? Lol.
It doesn't make any sense. So, she went by Stardust long before
you had an account. She just has tried changing up her branding.
Everyone knows her as as star or Stardust.
You don't get to own every name in the world at all times. If
she stopped calling herself that, then how dare you accuse me
of stealing. Okay, this does get back on Stardust. All right.
Are you talking to a mirror? because you're the only one who
keeps claiming uh claiming she stole Stardust from you when I
can definitively prove with date stamps you're lying. Actually
delusional when you're defending uh you lie about Stardust stealing
your name when you stole hers.
>> What is going on here? Is this like extremely complicated
gaslighting? Is this just like >> I don't know. Yeah, I
think I think Sadame is saying I don't Yeah, I don't know what
Sadame is doing here. This the the golem cannot understand sarcas
and the golem cannot see through it. Okay.
This is uh this is taxing resources from the NPC army. Okay,
this is what he's doing right now. What's delusional is you claiming
she stole Stardust from you when I have third party references
to prove you wrong. It doesn't matter that you don't know who
those parties are. The world doesn't revolve around you and you're
not important enough to force someone to change. This person
is just trolling. I wouldn't pay them any mind. Sardos goes,
"Hey yo,
shouldn't you be talking about how should you be talking somewhere
about sex crime somewhere? Shouldn't you shouldn't be out there?
Shouldn't you be out there saying how like some woman deserved
it? Shouldn't you be out there saying like, um, >> get
back get back to work. How'd you break out of the loop? What
the hees?
This person is trolling. [__] off. I was nice to
you and had a and had a genuine disagreement about a principal
position regarding Pixie's privacy and Cher's dignity. How dare
you hide cowardly behind petty accusations of trolling. You know
damn well what you did. You're >> I'm surprised has to
tell them like in tweets that they're trolling though because
I assume she could just put in the family group chat and they'd
say in
>> I think well I think what they do is they write the
golem instructions on a scroll and put it in the mouth. I think
that's should be how she informs them probably. But
>> I don't understand what's going on. I don't want to
know. >> Sorry. The family group chat's a good one though.
S
are you trolling me? Are you are you trolling me right now? You
lost her at principal position.
And and sick posts the the NPC meme from Westworld.
This accused me of being a bad empanada fan when I had already
denounced him in the denounced him in the conversation. The
>> Well, that's why she accused you, right? Just to irritate
you.
I think. Is this finally where we get the the Oh, no. It's not
yet. >> I think it's on one of the ones about the profile
picture change. Is it okay? Maybe we have to go all the way over
to >> Sick. I hope one day I have as much confidence as
you. I mean, I still wouldn't do personally, but again, I admire
the confidence to both do that and be psychotic online. Wait,
did sick >> I think that's what you >> guys about
the nude like whatever. >> I Well, yeah, that's just a
crazy thing. It's like, are you literally going to mock this
guy when he's like going, "Oh, I think you're I think you cape
for somebody who's done revenge." And you're gonna go, "Oh, yeah.
Well, I I I've seen some crazy images of you. You shouldn't be
you shouldn't be that confident.
That's
bizarre. Oh, right here. Okay. So, hey, small talk. If you're
going to change your name again, have you considered Bati Sole?
I don't that is only if I can call you GigasR the former IDF
superan or super fan. I
>> Batty seller. >> I prefer to be called Starduster
to be called Discount at Dan stream.
>> Why did she
Why did she bring Dan into >> I don't know, but Dan responds.
Oh, this psycho is gigas grand. Good. I love crushing these people.
Um
99% off an already product.
Um something just putting this here so I can follow them if they
name change.
Intent user. I don't even know what this is. I I can't imagine.
Listen,
>> bro. is >> I just I don't know how Dan could know.
So, how many followers does Sadame have? >> Do you think
Dan is all over Twitter trying to identify every person who's
ever like
>> sh him?
>> This is This is Yes. I think Dan will attack anybody
who's ever talked about him. I think Dan is this a less than
100 follower account. I think Dan will try to get into fights.
We saw this with the original guy he first docks, the the Glenn
the Golden guy or whatever. It's like he will take out people
who are like actually like skitsoids who are actually having
like crazy delusions. He will like dox them and harass them and
I'm like bro you got to stop. Like you please for the love of
God
>> is that like a hobby. >> I don't I just feel like
listen man just get a dog. >> No was in the that was in
the video the manga magic. There's like a there's a faction of
people who are struggling and that's why they buy into these
conspiracies. And then there are like really rich bored people
that want to feel like they are, >> you know,
>> in the cusp of doing something. >> Yeah. I feel
like Dan should get into Illuminati collection and lore like
Yeah. lore archiving or something like he should get into something
that's a cult instead of whatever this is. >> Get into
philosophy.
>> Does anybody know who the gig is ground is? I've seen
that guy in chat before. I've seen that name in chat for sure.
I don't know who it is beyond just like they're a chatter.
>> Anyway, this is the one that went quite long. Do we
have more after this? Yeah, because we have the whole profile
thing after this, don't we? >> Oh, yeah. The profile picture
change >> somewhere here. Stardust says like, "Hey, yeah."
So, she starts retweeting. She retweets a Dan Saltman tweet about
some random skitsoid deep in some thread. And then there's this
one. uh retweeting the sick, you know, you yeah, you are somebody
who should be blamed now and held accountable for the thing you
did when you were 10. And then, hey, help. I just changed my
PFP as a joke and now Twitter won't let me change it back. Get
this off my Twitter. Uh, and so what was the joke? Asks Sadame.
We have a good idea of what the joke was. Give me a second. This
load. Hello. The joke is something to do with Sardis is upset
she intentionally used a photo from a nude dump of me and wants
to erase the evidence. Girl, don't ever speak on Destiny or Pixar
or Cherry or anyone else. You're just as vile as the rest of
them. So apparently there's some nude dump. There's there's some
somebody did like revenge. This seems to be the allegation. And
within those photos
is a photo. It's included a photo where he's fully clothed, right?
And Sardos could say, "Well, I just found a fully clothed photo
of you or something." She could say that, but obviously we all
know what this is, right? You switch to this to imply, "Hey,"
to elbow the person and say, "Hey, I know about your dudes getting
leaked. I know about your revenge."
>> I think that's what Six's trying to communicate here.
And yes, she did say she did talk about him doing earlier,
>> Yeah, she did.
That she's not confident enough to >> Yeah. to do the way
he did. it's bold to have that face and do porn or whatever.
>> And so she's referenced that and now >> did he
do or is it just a nude dump of
>> I have I don't know I don't know any of the like truth
of this the the long and short of this. I don't know what it
is but um and maybe I don't know if Aiden had sick on. Maybe
Aiden asks him about what this is because I think Aiden was planning
to have sick on earlier today but I didn't get a chance to see
it. I heard about it, but I Yeah.
So, in any case, it seems pretty obvious to me that this is what
would be happening here is Stardust is basically going, "Yeah,
I know about this."
I don't know. Trying to menace him into stopping, I guess. Oh,
sorry. This is just a picture of the same thing. Okay,
so homie, you literally you're literally clothed in this pick.
What are you talking about? He says, "Destiny tactic. Point dismissed."
Again, I'm blocked by this guy across all platforms. You're just
crying victim after acting psycho. LMF fao. Small talk was blackmailing
you with nudes. That's a new low for the Destiny cult. Blackmail.
I'm sure she had the best of
When the snarking hits just right and then this is also his face.
I don't know why this is pixelated around it. I wonder, hold
on. I do wonder if this is actually a nude of some kind and he's
Donald Duck in it in this picture or something. I feel like that's
also a >> Do men
do that? That's weird. Uh, possibly. Oh, yeah. Here it is. Here's
another reference from sick to this.
My legal specialist tells me you could have quite a compelling
case here. Okay. All right. Tsunami. >> Is that Rose Malay?
>> That's Rose. Rose Malay has been in a couple of these
reply chains was being like, "What's going on here? What's going
on here? Somebody tell me what's going on here?" >> I saw
her under the one where he posts the logs with Airdite where
she's like, "Yeah, you're like getting stuff out of air." Like
I get stuff out of Brad Taste or whatever. I'm like is >> it
is quite similar actually.
>> It is quite similar.
>> It's so funny.
>> I wonder if
at tweets from star. You can call it hitting back, but if a man
posted you like that, it'd be chaos. That's the double standard
everyone pretends not to see. We got spider. Spider's in this
now. Let's go. >> Who's Spider again? >> Uh Lerbox's
clip channel editor. >> Oh, right. You guys were excited
cuz you knew. I knew it. He was 19
or whatever >> for for some reason. Yeah. Yeah. >> He
acts like a childish. Yeah. >> He acts like a child. Yeah.
So at tweets from Star Double Standard. And then from here we
go. Photo is not from a new dump. She says Stardo says
better says, "Come on now. I get it. But you've got to think
we are already we already get [__] on just for being
associated with loner box and all the past drama. All that past
drama. Even if the photo is not from a photo dump, posting it
just feeds the fire. To be honest, I don't associate Stardust
with Lerbox at all. I do associate spider.
Um, Stardust is kind of her own,
but that is an excellent point, bro.
Why? I don't know why she do that. Why is I'm not going to do
it. I'm not going to do it. She's in Loadbox. Well, no. Stardust
is Loner Box's editor on his YouTube if I'm not mistaken.
As in I believe she's employed by
Lonerbox. I just don't know why you would go and harass somebody
with this. Right. No need to quibble. It is. Oh, Omi, I didn't
know where this came from till you posted it.
>> Wait, what
is she not just transparently lying? Why was she talking about
him >> Yeah, none of us I still don't think that he did.
>> Also, her being Lonerbox's editor doesn't mean anything
to me here. Like, >> this isn't Lonerbox isn't retweeting
this or anything. >> Sure. Um, but I do believe DJers believe
that creators should be held responsible for their editor's actions.
Okay,
that is a that is a consistent argument from them. I'm sure they
will I'm sure they will apply this in the same way and it's still
stardust profile picture. Well, she is enough not to have understood
Riyle that when you change your profile picture on Twitter that
is locked in for a certain period of time. Uh, >> I don't
even know what the locking period is. >> They have to approve.
So it it >> Oh, so you can change, but they have to prove
you changing it back or changing something else. >> You
can't change anything until you get your check mark back. >> Okay.
Oh, right, right, right, right, right, right, right. I've seen
stuff like that happen when I change like something trivial and
the check mark goes away. It's kind of annoying, bro. Homie,
I didn't know where this came from till you posted it. Lol.
>> Bro, this is actually Stardust is actually like total
scum and she just gets away with it by being a tiny person that
nobody cares about. >> Tweet. What did he post?
>> What? This one? >> Yeah. What are these things?
>> This is apparently on some website is where his nudes
are leaked on the >> And it's literally like this is how
you would find it by looking on the internet is you would find
this
>> and she just wants to >> like you. Yeah. I don't
know with the comment about him doing I don't know if I really
buy it. I mean I don't buy it. She's been like gaslighting this
whole time. You just sound like really bitter that you were held
accountable. >> Oh, hold on. Um, the pixelation in the
photo. Where do we see this pixelated? Do we see it pixelated
before this from Stardust or something? I'm trying to think of
where we saw this cuz I'm looking for
this one cuz her profile picture does not seem to have the pixelation
on it, right? Am I crazy on that one? I don't know if I should
scroll all the way through this. Oh, yeah. No, Sardis did have
the pixelation. So, it does seem like she explicitly went or
someone around her explicitly went to reverse image search. This
is from a very popular reverse image search service. So, she's
either in a Discord with people who handed this to her or she
did it herself. Okay. It's just six Twitter. Okay. What's the
worst that could get posted? So,
I'm just curious. Did somebody not tell her what this was from?
Did nobody tell her what this was from? >> What the most
generous version is, oh, he does. This is from his >> I
like. >> And then she thinks that she's posting
>> pay. The only possible explanation here is that somebody
told her sik had leaked online and that they also provided this
picture, but they didn't put the two together for her. And so
she was taunting with this picture for some reason. She thinks
this picture is taunting, but she doesn't understand it's connected
to the even though they're explicitly saying that. Like I don't
I don't think there's any chance that that's the case. Right.
I know. I read the image description. I'm trying not to draw
too much attention to it here. Rain, assuming this is the tweet
I'm thinking of.
I literally I read it. I just don't want to go
draw attention to stuff, you know? >> Okay, how much more
can we get into
>> This isn't even on at this point. This is like just
straight up. She's being a total piece of like this is like totally
normal to like we've we've just walked through this. I I don't
even feel like we're getting on at all. I feel like I'm just
I just want to point out that she >> Mhm. explicitly is
trying to menace this guy with like revenge of him. It's obviously
Dan who sent it to her. Wouldn't it be crazy if you had some
reason to believe that Dan might be intimately familiar with
Pimise? I'm I'm just saying that would be crazy if you had reason
to believe that. Anyway, did did Spider did anyone go further
into this? I do think it's very bizarre that
they did this at all. Anyway, I that's probably the whole story.
Stardust seems like a totally just a total piece of I don't know
why she thought this was a good idea. Um, I mean, you can't say
this absolutely substance. I'm just I'm saying that
she obviously got pointed on to it by somebody and either they
set her up to look like a total [__] or
she's just lying. One of the two. I tried to get Sick and Stardust
to chill and end their beef. Both said no. Stardust been dealing
with non-stop hate for years, and I get why she's tired of it.
But saying six toxic mixed with H six toxic and mixed with H3
snarkers and warning me not to even talk to him while still firing
shots doesn't help. It just feeds the same cycle and sick you're
no better again. What has sick done here to Stardust specifically?
>> Oh, he made a joke about NYSE getting >> It's
literally like a a thing where he's mocking NYSE.
This is this is insane. This is sick is uh Darius, Spider is
Aerodite, and Stardust is Impath Chad. Okay, Stardust just did
something totally insane. Too sick. And now we have Spider over
here going, "You guys need to go away from each other. This is
just a bad This is bad juju when you guys mix it up." Okay, stop.
>> Group home, bro. This guy's actually
>> Yeah, but
be any more disabled than the average 19-year-old?
>> Yes, 100%.
I don't know about that, man. He's I don't know about that. >> He
He's like severely.
It just comes through all the time, >> dude. He's doing
his best. All right. He's a memer. He knows He knows how to meme.
Age docs. Someone said how old he was in my chat the other day.
Like one of his friends or something. I think it's like widely
known how old he is. I don't even know if I got it right. I'm
within a year. You thank you for the 20 months. Let's go. Okay,
keep going. Sick. You're no better. are acting like this is some
moral crusade when it's just personal drama wrapped in ego. You
talk about being mistreated, but keep throwing jabs like it's
a sport. At this point, both of you are fueling a fire that should
have burned out ages ago. I actually like Stardust. She's got
potential to rise above this. No, she doesn't. Never mind. Never
mind. No, I I doubted Quinn for a second there. Holy [__]
This is a crazy statement.
>> They they say that because they don't like Froggen.
So when Stardust is like an apple to somebody, it's like, "Oh,
but she's an [__] on my side." >> Oh, wait,
wait, wait, wait, wait. Yes, they are saying that. Sorry. Rise
above this as in this argument. Maybe Stardust has had a has
a shot at that possibly. >> I thought I thought rise in
terms of like being in >> a rising star. Only can do that.
>> Stardust not the right kind of minority right now. >> Not
even once. >> Uh but this constant back and forth makes
you both look stuck. Be the one who stops feeding it. Nobody's
impressed anymore. All right, purple memes. I hate this guy.
What is that gif? Start. Sorry. Spider just posts different memes
with like no context that are vaguely
connected sometimes, but usually not. That's That's how he rolls.
Okay.
>> That's just how he rolls. All right. What else? >> Like
a mental disability and he just like saw this like Star Wars
Tik Tok while he was scrolling Tik Tok or Instagram reals or
whatever >> and uh >> yeah, he's got a severe disability
so he just attaches. What's What's the >> Totally irrelevant.
>> Is there a problem with that? >> Um, that one's
not necessarily a problem in itself, but it's indicative of the
disability, which does cause many other
this Sarah the raging tomato went live tonight and then she shut
off all the stuff where you could go through the VODs and now
it's like
she hasn't ended and she's also not sure if she's going to keep
the VOD up. I need to watch this. I need to watch her response.
It doesn't have to be tonight, but like she can't do a stream
like that and never post it anywhere. Otherwise, what's the point?
>> I want to I just want to see what she said about Rob.
Sucks. >> Did Rob stream? Did he react to any of >> I
don't know if Rob reacted to it. Rob definitely streamed though.
>> What if he had it up? What if he reacted >> Rob
no
just did this 10 minutes ago.
>> That will Yeah.
>> Like they were ISIS.
So the
>> what do you guys think of speak easy taking over all
of the right-wing political debates?
I feel like there's no way but maybe >> idea that we have
are white. Uh >> we witnessing the rise of speak easy.
>> Uh but as you we were saying so um
how funny party at 20,000. Keep up the great work brother. Love
the content. I make an act of myself rapping here and there but
I'm not looking to make it a whole >> You didn't do it.
He didn't do the
He didn't do this content. >> He's above it. He said what
he said. Honestly, it just looks like he had scheduled content.
>> Dude,
uh Lumpy Willy sighting in one of these threads. Sorry, I was
just scrolling through a couple more of these things here really
quickly. Um so, so conspiracy lemur comes along and says, "Okay,
Stardust, why did you talk about in this tweet?"
Right?
To which Lumpy Willie then comes down and responds, "Hey at tweets
from Star, does this virtual feel better or worse than the real
one your dead Indian dad used to do to you when you were 15?"
That's just uncalled for, Lumpy Willy. That's really That's really
up, Lumpy. I don't know why Lumpy Willie would say that.
>> Why Why did Why did Lumpy Willie feel the need to come
and say this? That's >> That's wild.
Why did Lumpy Willie do this? I got I I have to disavow. Okay.
I don't appreciate Lumpy Willy doing this at >> That's
really That was a bit too far. That's a little bit over the line,
Lumpy >> That's fake, huh? That's fake. >> That's
a little That's a little over the line. I just I double clicked.
I don't know what to do now. Okay, I got to back out here.
All right. All right. All right. All right. Uh we had raging
tomato stuff. What else we got tonight? I was thinking about
looking at some of the the New York City debate, but >> that
Hutch Josiah combo from Hutch's stream was very interesting.
>> Oh, like the whole thing. >> Like the actual Hutch
Josiah
>> Did he publish it? Did he publish like a full video?
>> It would probably >> I don't know if he he had
to have, >> Does he put up his VODs? I feel like he just
leaves his VODs unlisted and he never links >> right there
with the angry Josiah face.
>> it's all cope. Live and learn. Take a
>> Your way has gotten us here. We're taking no risks with
the Supreme Court.
>> Oh, okay.
All right. It's a long convo. We check some of this out. >> We
don't have to watch it now, but keep >> Well, I just I
mean, we don't have to watch it now, but also I've got like we
had we had a couple things. What else do we got? I I thought
we were going to have the raging tomato stuff tonight, so I just
don't have very much else. I could go look at what else we got
for the night. There also is a chance that people have been loading
up one of these channels with links to funny stuff
>> Oh, that guy that
>> uh No, go ahead. >> There is actually Yeah, I
was going to say there is actually I found this state. There
is actually a moment in that Drew Pablo Lone Box conversation
where Lone Box does address the fact that that Drew is calling
him.
>> you guys were watching that. >> Uh, wait, was
that on stream or after stream? Was it after stream? Well, >> wait,
wait, wait. We watched No, no, no. We didn't watch it after stream.
It was on stream. >> Yeah, that was on stream.
>> Oh, we had a Patreon call last night. Straight raid
ended up coming in at like 4 in the morning and then she hung
out and talked about politics. It was good time. Good time. Uh,
what else do we got here? Wait, do you want to link me though,
Drew? Are you Do you want to watch Motorbox? Go. Hey, Lou. Hey,
I need to see that actually.
>> How long did it take? Let me get a time
>> to stop.
>> Please stop calling me. I'm Lebanese.
>> Do you feel like he gets to make a stronger argument
by not correcting that he's not? >> No, I don't think so.
>> No. Okay, >> I don't think so. Oh, >> also
the the Z,
>> what was her name? Z Tyler Coleman. What is her name
again? >> Wait, hold on. Wait. Is there like a conspiracy
around this? Sorry, I'm going a totally different direction.
>> You go. You go. the chess GM who died. Is there like
a conspiracy about this that I was unaware of? >> Did he
also have something up his ass?
>> I don't think so, but apparently he um all of his Twitch
content was cleared entirely and people think he had like some
kind of breakdown on stream. >> Oh, well that's not funny.
I didn't mean to make a joke. >> No, but hold on.
>> It's just the last chess drama that there was, the dude
like cheated by having like a vibrator in his ass. I think people
said,
>> that can be dangerous."
>> Hold on. What What What was his Twitch channel? Let
me find his Twitch channel really quick. Uh, his Twitch channel
was
GM Naraditsky. That's what I thought it was. What the [__]
I've got 23 VODs that I've got on stream recorder to go and look
at this guy's [__] While you look for that, the
Z Cohan person
where she like she tweeted out how big her crowd was and then
she >> added another person who goes to universities to
do debates. >> Oh yeah, we covered that one, right? >> Yeah,
but he replied, "Did you cover >> Yeah, he totally owned
her.
>> Oh, okay. >> We did cover that earlier tonight.
>> Um I thought that was funny. >> Who was it? I
That was a guy who's like in Twitch politics. He's like, "I've
debated Destiny multiple times. So, you never asked me to debate
him. Like, literally, I would have debated him, but now you're
kind of actually a weirdo. So, go [__] yourself.
What do we need? We need What did Cam Link Cam Link
>> if you had to describe Glen? >> What? What is
this, Cam? Who is this related to
>> How would you kind of summarize it? >> Um, it
could really be anything. Um, I just, you know, I have my take
on Glennfall's music. Um, but it could it could really be anything.
Um, any type of music coming from the Glenn Falls >> Okay.
All right. Well, hey, we're gonna let you play. Uh, so take it
away. >> Oh, no. >> Do I want to get that mic off?
>> What is that guy dressed like that?
>> I don't know. >> What the hell? >> What
is happening?
>> Are you okay? >> Honey, did you hurt yourself?
>> Wow. Okay, that was uh Wow. Mhm. Okay. So, now it makes
sense where I was like, where do you get your inspiration? Okay,
I get it. I get it. Um, wow. A lot of power with that. >> A
lot of passion. >> You know, I am going to get that microphone
back though so we can hear you if that's okay. Thank you. >> I
just got to turn off. >> there he is. >> That was
all right. Excellent. >> Glenn Paul's music.
>> guys, I think um I think we're like eight subsish away
from two more hours in the stream if you wanted to throw some
subs in. Otherwise, maybe
>> you know when I when I think of Glenn Falls, I think
of like like a very
>> time foring
not litterbox disgusted by the allegation eventually by >> Drew.
Drew Drew knew that if he called him enough times, he would pull
out the the deep-seated anti-semitism in Lonerbox's soul where
he'd go like, "Ah, stop saying it. Stop." >> Cultural continuity
of the nation is something that's very important to me and I
think it would be bad like like do you think Okay. about whether
or not we can have a functioning healthare system for our old
people. >> You win. >> Oh, hold on. Legally black.
Thank you for the five gifted subs. Let's go. >> Okay.
Okay. Loader box. Loader box. What do you think is a more important
question in Israeli politics? Whether the tax rate should be
raised 2 or 3%. >> I don't know why you keep trying to
appeal to Israel. Israel is a country with so much more unique
challenges than the UK. Like you know, you know full well that
do not have the same experience with demographics as white people
in England.
It is not a comparable experience. Why are you doing that, >> dude?
This is This is Hold on. Hold on. Hold on. >> We're both
This is part of my This is part of my question for Lon Box, actually.
Jewish,
>> Well, I I know you're a Zionist, so we're both Zionists.
>> A Zionist in what sense? In what? That I think Israel
shouldn't be destroyed. That's as far as it goes for me. >> That's
me. Same with me, too. Same with me, too. Just because I think
Israel shouldn't be destroyed because they're in a very unique
position in the world does not mean that I'm going to tremble
at the thought of like demographics shifting in somewhere like
the UK as they already have in certain cities.
>> Yeah. But yeah, but it hasn't >> Dude, no way.
Why? What? Why? >> Because I can because because I if you're
going to talk about demographics
do you think it's a good thing that >> demographics is
just about it's your >> Just say it's destiny loner box.
That's all you got to say. >> It's your ethnic makeup.
It's your origin, your national origin. It can be about culture
and preferences, but you'd have to show me why there is a specific
reason why this or that demographic can't be a minority. I can
make that.
>> Okay, hold on. Hold on. No, I'm going to I'm going to
throw a flag on the play because this question goes directly
to this point and then I'm going to question for you, Drew. >> We
got a flag on the play, guys.
We're throwing a flag on the play. All right, quick flag on the
play. Box realizing the consequences of his own rhetoric. Um,
I don't think so. But I I feel like comparing Lord Box to Drew
Pavlo is pretty crazy. >> Drew Pablo is like he's like
the, you know, in terms of his Israel takes,
he's like the average DJ.
It's like how they sound. >> All right.
Uh, did you maybe did you look into the platiner stuff at all?
>> What is that? >> You don't know what I'm talking
about? the you know the um you remember the military guy Hassan
was shilling for
um that people were getting mad at him about it's like a guy
who used to be a mercenary or something remember this >> oh
is he being like hired by China or
>> no
gentlemen here we go >> where Porter brother where did
you get this yamas
clearly AI generated all right uh no he had a tattoo that's the
big thing tattoo >> oh I saw There was some guy was being
hired to like train people in. I thought it was the same military
guy, but I guess not.
>> Uh, no, different thing. I guess this guy's running
for Congress. He might be running for the Senate even, >> but
he's he's running for position. >> As I was getting up,
I think I heard Chad talking about this on stream.
>> Yeah, he had like
>> tattoo and he claimed that
what he got it while he was drunk or something. He got it saying
that they walked into a tattoo parlor in Croatia with like his
mercenary buddies and they basically were like, "Let's all get
the same tattoo and it was a toten like cross." Yeah. But listen,
the last time I heard something was a toteen cough. It was the
like board ape thing and I'm like, I don't know. It's like >> I
don't know, man.
>> I think sometimes people like overplay it. I just have
to see it. I've not seen what the what the tattoo looks like,
right? I'd have to see the tattoo.
Um,
yeah. I think there's just people really